cher François cher tout ça fait déjà
trois fois que je suis invité à cette
journée de Guidel c'est toujours un
immense plaisir et tu l'as rappelé je
fais aussi un peu partie de la famille
je suis votre président le groupe au
Parlement européen et c'est avec
fierté la table ronde la démontrer tout
à l'heure une grande fierté
de tous les combats politiques que nous
avons gagné depuis 5 ans avec les
parlementaires du MoDem avec les
parlementaires d'horizon avec les
parlementaires de en marche qui forment
cette grande famille je pense que nous
avons changé je le disais l'année
dernière déjà partie de
la manière dont était perçues la classe
politique dans cet institution qui est
le Parlement européen c'est grâce à vous
c'est grâce au parlementaire je voulais
leur rendre hommage et rendre un hommage
appuyé aussi à Mariel qui a beaucoup
œuvré
à développer
votre influence notre influence au
Parlement européen
dans cette dernière dans ces dernières
années je vais peut-être revenir je
serai pas long mais peut-être sur la
table ronde d'avant François pour
expliquer aussi
nos relations politiques après puisque
il y a une très grande cohérence
j'étais
hier en Italie pour conclure les
meetings politiques de nos
de nos partis frères au niveau européen
qui se battent aujourd'hui pour éviter
l'arrivée du populisme aux portes de
l'Europe toujours l'occasion de dire que
les élections nationales sont des
élections européennes elles sont des
élections européennes parce que elles
détermine aussi au Conseil de l'Europe
choisi un premier ministre détermine
aussi le devenir des citoyens européens
de tous les États membres et ça prend
d'autant plus d'importance aujourd'hui
quand on a vécu la première partie de
ces années 2020
et cette année 2020 ont quand même
bouleversé un certain nombre de choses
qui aujourd'hui rendent encore plus
important et j'y vais y revenir l'unité
le rassemblement ensemble qui est pas un
mauvais que nous avons à construire et
nous avons encore à faire vivre pendant
ces 5 prochaines années
je le dis parce que l'adversaire de
notre famille politique au sens large de
notre rassemblement de notre coalition
restera malheureusement encore dans les
prochaines années on le voit se
développer un peu partout en Europe les
extrémistes l'extrême droite notamment
et on l'a bien vu que ces crises ont
apporté beaucoup de bien le tableau rond
de la démontrer les pâtes géants qu'on a
fait sur la construction européenne les
pâtes géants qu'on a fait sur la
construction y compris de l'Europe de la
défense les pas de géants qu'on a fait y
compris dans la tête des Européens quand
les Européens sont venus protéger les
populations mais mine de rien les
derniers prochaines crises
l'augmentation du de l'énergie
l'inflation va aussi drainer un certain
nombre de phénomènes bien connus en
Europe l'inflation
le jeu des populistes tout ça ce sera
évidemment un des grands enjeux de 2024
un des grands enjeux sur lequel moi je
veux qu'on puisse travailler avec une
force importante on est en train de
constituer en Europe un pôle des
progressistes des démocrates des
libéraux qui doit faire face et je fais
le parallèle parce que la presse
italienne m'interrogeait sur la
situation française
les amis de part deux fois en 2017 et en
2022 nous avons été le barrage aux
extrémistes ne vous laissez pas mettre
dans les cordes par d'ailleurs nos
opposants qui souvent nous accusent de
soit les faire monter quand les dénonce
ou soit de les mettre en valeur quand on
les combats mais par deux fois en 2017
et en 2022 notre coalition de fait a
fait barrage éventuellement à l'arrivée
des extrémistes en France et notamment
du Front national du rassemblement
national et de l'ensemble des des
responsables politiques qui drainent
cette cette idéologie donc il faut qu'on
soit fier de ça fier de ça parce que je
me rappelle du contexte et Edouard
Philippe et François Baillot s'en
rappellent également du conseil de 2017
heureusement que nous avions cette
famille politique le MoDem qui est venu
avec nous qui a constitué une coalition
et quand on voit après quand c'est
prolongé c'est constitué cette élection
de 2017 avec les affaires à droite
l'incapacité de la gauche de se
rassembler
quel aurait été le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle en 2017 est-ce
que les Français n'auraient pas eu à
faire aux extrêmes ou aux extrêmes
peut parfois avoir une forme de
d'approche je partage là dessus François
paillerou ou peut faire les loges de la
différence tout en faisant l'éloge de
l'unité et je pense que c'est ce que
nous a aussi c'est mutuellement entre
tenu mutuellement créer une culture
politique commune sur sur ces questions
là et je pense que c'est possible et
depuis 5 ans nous le vivons comme ça et
je pense qu'on a réussi en tout cas dans
cette dans cette dynamique à pouvoir le
démontrer
à l'inverse d'ailleurs aujourd'hui de la
nupesse qui était qu'une alliance
électorale peut-être de circonscription
et de circonstances mais on voit bien
les difficultés aujourd'hui de faire
cette alliance pour gouverner les
oppositions se sont alliés pour
s'opposer on a décidé de s'allier pour
gouverner le pays ce qui est déjà une
chose beaucoup plus compliquée quand on
sait les mécanismes qui nous amènent aux
responsabilités donc là dessus aussi
c'est un deuxième élément de fierté je
pense de cette organisation collective
et puis le MoDem a été aussi je le dis
François vous avez été
et je le dis aussi
à Guidel d'autant plus de manière
d'autant plus convaincue vous avez
apporté des choses à cette majorité je
pense notamment cette humanisme et tout
ce qui traverse aujourd'hui les
politiques publiques qu'on peut nous
aussi concevoir d'abord vous le savez
tu es le diplômé de l'être classique qui
qui sait ce que c'est l'humanisme
l'émancipation de l'homme nous aussi
nous y croyons vous avez apporté aussi
cette dimension l'épanouissement
individuel la question notamment de
l'héritage que nous pouvons avoir dans
notre vie politique autour de cette
belle majorité vous avez participé en
tout cas à construire
cette doctrine et ses valeurs que nous
avons aujourd'hui tous partagé et que je
partage aussi dans Renaissance quand on
regarde l'ensemble des militants cette
dimension humaniste est également
présente et c'est aussi
grâce à vous je pense notamment à
l'Europe on en a parlé longuement mais
vous avez pas été des Européens et on
peut intermittent dans la période ce
parti est cohérent cette organisation et
ce mouvement est cohérent vous avez su
déjà des 2017 je me rappelle très bien
ici à Guidel en parlant
de l'Europe de la défense peut-être même
en premier Jean-Yves Le Drian le disait
que on avait des difficultés à pouvoir
convaincre nos partenaires mais déjà à
l'époque cette question là était posée
dès 2017 dans un des partis politiques
français qui a progressé et donc vous
avez aussi participé à ça et puis enfin
peut-être la question de proportionnelle
j'étais à peu près sûr de mon coup
question de proportionnelle j'ai la j'ai
la conviction il faudra interroger
d'ailleurs les militants de Renaissance
on aura également ce débat entre nous
mais j'ai la conviction que la
composition de l'Assemblée nationale
montre que les Français aspirent à une
meilleure représentativité des forces
politiques au Parlement ils nous l'ont
montré par les élections faut maintenant
passer de peut-être la proportionnelle
de fait imposer en quelque sorte à la
proportionnelle choisie
organisée par nos institutions et donc
ça sera un débat qu'on aura entre
formation politique mais c'est un débat
que je veux mener avec aussi
l'intelligence de votre approche qui est
longue sur le terrain et puis votre
conviction sur ces sujets là voilà il y
aura
il y aura évidemment des choix à faire
dans les dans les prochains mois et dans
les prochaines semaines sur les
politiques publiques évidemment
on aura peut-être je le disais des
approches différentes mais nous pourrons
toujours faire l'éloge de l'unité c'est
le cas sur la réforme des retraites où
je pense que sincèrement le comme tu le
dis souvent François également c'est un
projet de société et pas un choix
budgétaire je partage aussi cette
conviction on connaît tous le point
d'atterrissage on a le droit d'avoir des
discussions de comment on y va ça n'a me
gêne pas et c'est débats sont plutôt
saints dans une majorité qui peut vivre
c'est une question de sincérité mais
c'est aussi une question de vie
collectif si on veut que ce cela dure et
dans tout collectif si on veut que ça
dure il faut pouvoir faire vivre ce
collectif avec ses différences et ses
sensibilités ces sensibilités
différentes et j'en serai aussi le
garant à ma place la mienne j'ai
beaucoup travaillé
avec les parlementaires européens on est
maintenant 103 parlementaires de 25
nationalités différentes de 40 partis
politiques différentes partout en Europe
avec évidemment
une
géographie différentes des intérêts
différents des fois mais ça nous empêche
pas de voter à 95% la même chose dans
l'hémicycle après avoir fait des débats
après avoir construit des compromis
après avoir organisé nos débats internes
qui sont pas des prises de gueule entre
les uns les autres mais des débats
constructifs je pense qu'on peut y
arriver pendant ces cinq dernières
années tout simplement parce que les
Français nous regardent et que nous
sommes en responsabilité
et les Français peuvent être parfois
très durs avec les gens qui sont en
responsabilité et nous le devons aussi
cette exigence de débat mutuel je
regarde notamment le PS qui a
dissolu un peu près tout ce qui était de
ces valeurs et de ses idées dans le
mélange chenille la droite qui ferait de
plus en plus dont les digues sont en
train de se s'effondrer avec l'extrême
droite alors on est le pôle de stabilité
de ce pays il faut l'assumer avec des
responsabilités derrière je pense on est
devenu les seules parties de
gouvernement aujourd'hui quand on écoute
les responsables politiques dans les
médias et dans leurs interventions
publiques alors c'est avec une immense
responsabilité que nous assumons
l'humilité dans l'unité et aujourd'hui
et demain et après-demain en tout cas je
l'espère merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]